bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
devant les parlementaires socialistes à
tour le premier ministre annonce une
nouvelle étape tout en gardant le cap au
chapitre des réformes celle du cumul des
mandats de scruter régionales et
sénatoriales mais aussi une refonte de
l'audiovisuel public
invité de ce journal madame catherine
trautmann lise la culture et la
communication réquisitoire au procès de
florence rey devant les assises de paris
trente ans de réclusion requis pour les
quatre meurtres commis en 1994 le
centième salon de l'auto ouvrira ses
portes jeudi à paris ce soir nous ferons
la découverte de plusieurs nouveautés un
nouvel album de jane birkin intitulé à
la légère c'est le premier album sans
serge gainsbourg jane birkin et puis
cette information livrée dans le courant
de l'après-midi par l'hôpital du val de
grâce monsieur jean pierre chevènement
va mieux il a quitté le service de soins
intensifs et l'évolution respiratoire
est très satisfaisante précise l'équipe
médicale qui suit me l'intérieur depuis
le 2 septembre date à laquelle il fut
victime d'un arrêt cardiaque alors jean
daniel flaysakier maintenant que va-t-il
se passer
la première chose c'est que le ministre
va rester à l'hôpital c'est la première
information mais de non plus dans un
service de soins intensifs mais viendra
services de soins banal on va s'occuper
lui ont valu faire sont certainement
beaucoup de rééducation parce qu'il ya
dû y avoir une énorme fonte de ses
muscles pendant ce mois qu'il a passés
dans le coma il va faire donc lui permet
de retrouver des muscles retrouver des
articulations qui fonctionne et puis
surtout probablement l'aider
psychologiquement un ce qu'on appelle un
débriefing il va certes on arrive à une
série de souvenirs qui vont s'accumuler
dans sa tête des émotions
on va lui raconter des choses il va
falloir que l'assistante si une
assistance psychologique se mettent en
place pour l'aider à surmonter ce qu'a
failli être un événement tragique dans
sa vie le dernier on est quand même
surpris par la rapidité sa a coté quasi
miraculeux cette reprise est moyen la
partie en domaine du religieux est long
mais je dirais de la médecine ya d'abord
eu une formidable équipes
d'anesthésistes et leurs animateurs
c'est une des plus brillantes en france
et le problème de ce côté là
ne se posait pas parce que ce sont des
gens qui connaissent merveilleusement
leur travail et aussi la volonté du
patient qu'il soit jean pierre
chevènement ou un autre quand quelqu'un
n'a pas envie de mourir elle s'accroche
à la vie je crois que on connaît le
caractère de jean pierre chevènement ce
n'est pas très surprenant quand
quelqu'un s'accroche c'est du domaine du
non quantifiable on peut pas mesurer là
dessus on n'a aucun moyen de savoir mais
quand des gens ont envie de rester
vivant et de se bagarrer de s'accrocher
ils le font et tous les jours en
médecine on voit des gens que l'on
retient comme perdue arriver à s'en
sortir
depuis cette affaire j'ai rencontré à
plusieurs reprises des anesthésistes
réanimateurs qui m'ont raconté des
accidents similaires avec des gens durs
sont ressorties pratiquement sans
séquelles alors est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il a subi un traitement banal comme
tout le monde pour ses jambes notamment
où est ce qu'il ya eu une mesure de
moyens exceptionnels
alors je crois qu'il faut dire une chose
très importante les soins dont a
bénéficié le ministre jean pierre
chevènement sont des soins dont
bénéficierait madame ou monsieur tout le
monde dans la même situation il n'y a
pas eu de traitement entre guillemets de
faveur parce qu'on avait un ministre
dans une clé dans une situation
catastrophique
c'est la règle lorsque les patients sont
intubés lorsque l'oxygène arrive dans
les poumons qu'on sait que le massage
cardiaque va être assez efficace parce
que autour de la table il ya
suffisamment de médecins et de
personnels spécialisés
c'est la règle de masse et longtemps une
heure c'est le standard il n'y a donc
pas eu de favoritisme
ça a marché c'est formidable il faut
aussi que chacun d'entre nous sachions
que si nous devions nous retrouver dans
une situation aussi délicate on n'en
bénéficiera des mêmes soins ça je crois
que c'est très important
la médecine ça commence par l'égalité
dans les domaines les plus difficiles
comme ça merci jean malienne le premier
ministre a rendu visite ce matin jean
pierre chevènement et celui ci lui
aurait déclaré quand j'ai retrouvé ma
voix je me suis mis à chanter
fort de cette bonne nouvelle monsieur
lionel jospin s'est rendu à tours où se
tenait les journées parlementaires du
parti socialiste le chef du gouvernement
a exprimé sa volonté de poursuivre la
politique entreprise depuis 16 mois il
veut garder le cap tout en marquant une
nouvelle étape avec une série de
réformes concernant aussi bien la parité
homme-femme des modes de scrutins
électoraux la réforme de l'audiovisuel
public dont nous parlerons dans quelques
instants
et puis voyez ce reportage sur ces
journées parlementaires avec lionel
jospin reportage de françoise david et
frederick de la rue à tour aujourd'hui
il y avait trois petits cochons venu à
la ville savoir quelle sauce et à quel
prix ils allaient être mangés
à tours aujourd'hui il y avait aussi un
premier ministre qui fit un détour pour
parler surproduction alors pour tout
repère médiane léger spa n'était pas
venu que pour cela accompagné de
nombreux ministres
il était là pour expliquer aux
parlementaires socialistes quelle serait
leur travail pour les neuf mois à venir
la méthode afficher le dialogue et la
concertation mais aussi la fermeté le
sénat s'opposent à la réforme du cumul
des mandats
ganesh d'espacé fâche la volonté du
gouvernement est totale chacun prendra
ses responsabilités et nous verrons le
moment venu
comment nous poursuivrons une réforme
essentielle et à laquelle nos
concitoyens tester le thème dans vos
meetings messieurs les élus et mesdames
sont très profondément attaché françois
hollande lui aussi a choisi une cible
c'est le cnps accusé de détourner le
sens et l'esprit de la loi sur les 35
heures pour en limiter les effets sur
l'emploi
le législateur ne restera pas inerte
et puisqu'une deuxième loi est prévu
affirme honnêtement qu elle encadrera
strictement le recours aux heures
supplémentaires
chacun est désormais prévenu budget ou
ratification du traité d'amsterdam
autant de gros dossier qui risque de
faire tanguer la majorité plurielle
aujourd'hui les dirigeants socialistes
ont préféré concentré leurs attaques sur
l'opposition
alors parmi les projets du premier
ministre donc la nouvelle réforme de
l'audiovisuel
elle vous et nous concerne ce projet
sera discuté par les députés au mois de
décembre
il vise à restreindre la publicité sur
france 2 et france 3 et à créer un grand
groupe de télévision publique
selon monsieur jospin explications
patricia charnolé pascal caron la
réforme de l'audiovisuel public est un
projet politique important a dit lionel
jospin cet après midi pour le premier
ministre les entreprises de ce secteur
ne doivent pas obéir à une logique de
profit
elles doivent servir de modèle en
matière de qualité des programmes
d'éthique de l'information et de
démocratisation de la culture la
télévision doit être un instrument de
cohésion sociale fédérer les publics
autour des missions de qualité organisé
le débat
exprimant la diversité de la société
distraire en maintenant un réel niveau
d'exigence première mesure envisagée la
création d'une holding soit un grand
groupe réunissant france 2 france 3 et
la cinquième art et son président sera
nommé pour cinq ans par le csa le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
deuxième priorité v définir la
spécificité de chaque chaîne france 2
généralistes france 3 régional et local
la 5ème art et éducatives et culturelles
à dimension européenne
troisième point fort une réduction très
importante de la publicité
près de 50% en moins ce manque à gagner
pour les chaînes sera compensée par des
crédits budgétaires
un changement qui devrait être visible à
l'antenne dès l'an 2000 le plus
spectaculaire serait la diminution des
écrans de publicité sur les chaînes
publiques sous réserve bien sûr des
discussions et détails à venir il est
toujours utile de comparer ce qui fait
ce qui se fait chez nos voisins
européens
ainsi en grande-bretagne la publicité
est interdite sur la bbc ou extrêmement
limité en allemagne voici un parallèle
concernant les ressources publicitaires
la redevance
entre les télévisions publiques
françaises d'une part et ses homologues
européennes d'autre part à noter qu'il y
à tout juste 30 ans la pub arrivait sur
vos écrans commentaires hervé brusini au
début il n'y avait pas de publicité à la
télé le propriétaire d'un post payés et
paye toujours la redevance les en 68 la
publicité de marque est apparu dans la
petite lucarne
mais si et ça même tout changé pour les
ressources des chaînes de service public
en 96 sur les quelques 5 milliard 300
millions de chiffre d'affaires de france
2 48 % viennent de la redevance et plus
de 51 % des recettes commerciales dont
45% de pub au sens strict du terme
en revanche quand l'usager angles et
choisit la bbc qu'il n'y a pas de
publicité sur les deux chaînes de
service public
en 96 la redevance a procuré 76% des
ressources de nos amis anglais son
montant n'est pas plus élevé qu'en
france
là-bas la télé à d'autres revenus elle
est grande exportatrice le programme et
a développé d'importantes activités
commerciales c'est comme cela que les
trois chaînes de la rai italienne
annonce leur page de pub et comme cela
deux grandes vedettes du petit écran à
l'image de cette dame blonde font de la
pub
une pub qui représente avec d'autres
recettes commerciales plus de 41 % du
budget la redevance elle 51%
en allemagne la présentatrice de la
météo c'est que les chaînes de son pays
ont strictement réglementée la pub elle
est obligatoirement absente après 20h
jamais le dimanche et certains jours
fériés ou si dur elle lui fait chaque
jour pour faire la réclame c'est un peu
plus de 15% du budget de la zdf par
exemple la redevance près de 72% et à
nos cousins d'espagne sont eux de vrais
consommateurs leur télévision de service
public vit principalement de la
publicité 62% 96 pas de redevances le
décret qu'il avait instaurée en 47 fut
supprimée en 65
le 62 % ce n'est pas 100% dirait vue
alors si la télé appel au secours pour
son budget les pouvoirs publics comble
les trous créatures hybrides
c'est ce qu'on appelle une télévision
commerciale d'état entretenons bonsoir
alors bon on va suisse que deezer et
vous signé avec quoi nous allons faire
une télévision publique de qualité dont
on vient de parler même si j'ose pas
puisque vous allez nous retirer de
l'argent
alors d'abord je voudrais bien dire que
c'est une réforme majeure et qui est
très importante pour l'ensemble des
français puisqu'il s'agit d'abord de
répondre à leurs attentes
les français consacrent en moyenne trois
heures par jour devant leur écran de
télévision une réforme ambitieuse en
matière de service public et donc très
très sensible supprimer les tunnels de
publicité sur france 2 et france 3 s'est
félicité ça veut dire pour expliquer
leur colle yeux de voir 14 minutes ils
enverraient combien ils environ cinq
minutes par heure ça serait la
nomination à sa minute par c'est la
notation au lieu de 12 au maximum
autorisé aujourd'hui
cela veut dire ça me fait plaisir et
démocrate porté de l'argent et les
permettait de faire des programmes de
faire de l'information
alors avec quoi allons-nous financer ce
que nous faisons nous télévision
publique alors nous allons financer ce
manque à gagner de recettes
publicitaires par des crédits
budgétaires inscrits au budget de l'état
je rassure tout de suite tous les
aspects des téléspectateurs cela ne veut
pas dire pour autant qu'ils paieraient
plus d'impôts pour la télévision ou la
radio publique puisque la somme qui va
compenser cette baisse de crédits
publicitaires représentent un millième
du budget de l'état donc pas d'impôts
mais en même temps
d'augmentation de redevances pour autant
puisque nous estimons la redevance
excusez-moi doit avoir un niveau
raisonnable et une progression limitée
pour les téléspectateurs et c'est bien
l'allemagne
en allemagne la redevance elle est
quasiment le double de la nôtre pourquoi
est-ce que vous quoi ce qu'on n'augmente
pas franchement la redevance et qu'on
dit très franchement qu'une télévision
publique
ça nécessite de l'argent il se fait
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous allez pas
jusque là
d'abord il faut donner les moyens à la
télévision publique d'être une
télévision qui prend des risques qui est
créative et qui peut affronter avec tous
ses moyens
la révolution technologique il y à la
fois la créativité l'innovation et la
réduction de la publicité va permettre
d'avoir plus tôt par exemple ses
émissions du soir d'avoir une meilleur
enchaînement des émissions mais il faut
en même temps aussi répondre on l'a vu
les gens entre télévisions européennes
veulent exporter leurs programmes nous
devons le faire aussi nous n'avons
aucune raison de ne pas être fier donne
au programme life a répondu c'est l'art
elle avance sur la redevance pourquoi ne
pas l'avoir aussi élevés que d'autres
pays tout simplement parce que nous
partons d'une situation différente
aujourd'hui en france le choix qui a été
fait à un moment donné c'est de limiter
les crédits de l'état et l'état n'a pu
remplir ses responsabilités aujourd'hui
lorsque l'état dit je compense la baisse
de ressources publicitaires par des
crédits budgétaires il assume sa
responsabilité d'actionnaire
c'est ce que l'on doit aux
téléspectateurs ou à l'auditeur qui
payent la redevance et c'est donc
justice de procéder ainsi
alors on a fait un petit calcul vous
allez donnez vous à les remettre sur le
marché publicitaire commis entre 1 et 2
milliards à peu près l'équivalent de 1,2
milliard là représentent environ environ
2 milliards de francs 2 milliards de
francs les deux milliards ils vont aller
directement chez nos concurrents et amis
évidemment de tf1 de m6 ils vont être
très très content et la télévision
publique il va faire comment pour
combler cet écart qui va s'agrandir
je pense que sur ses rayons que vous
avez fait comme moi vous avez peut-être
lu ce matin un article dans le figaro
qui indiquait les propos d'annonceurs
qui envisage très clairement une
redistribution pour une part de ces
sommes et des annonces vers la presse
écrite vers les chaînes thématiques
ouverts larrazet ira évidemment vers les
gros mais ces médias ces médias manquent
de ressources c'est une bonne chose
s'ils peuvent en bénéficier pour le
reste ce qui apparaîtrait comme un
enrichissement sans cause
c'est à dire comme des recettes
qui viendrait en quelque sorte
spontanément vers les chaînes privées
nous y avons pensé le gouvernement
prévoit un dispositif qui permettra au
vu des sommes qui seraient collectées
ainsi de les reprendre une partie et de
l'ecc ans ne consacrer ses recettes à la
production à la création du visuel
je remercie fin de la grève à radio
france un accord a été trouvé entre les
syndicats et la direction mais enfin ce
mouvement qui est fêtée france culture
france musique ainsi que certaines
émissions de france inter 48 heures
après la victoire du social-démocrate
monsieur gerhard schröder en allemagne
le président jacques chirac évoque dans
une tribune publiée par le figaro ce
matin les rapports franco allemand le
temps est venu de rénover la relation
franco allemande estime le chef de
l'état qui recevra demain ainsi que
monsieur jospin monsieur schröder à
paris devant la cour d'assises l'avocat
général a requis trente ans de réclusion
criminelle contre florence rey et dix
ans de même peine contre son co accusé
ces peines ont été réclamés pour quatre
meurtres et tentatives de meurtres
commis au mois d'octobre 1994 alors
dominique verdeilhan on s'attendait
plutôt à une peine une réquisition pour
la perpétuité caisse pourquoi est ce que
l'avocat général a changé
oui effectivement florence rey encourait
la réclusion en cours toujours la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité alors
eu égard au fait que florence rey et
audry maupin ne sont pas des terroristes
ce ne sont pas bonnie and clyde ira même
l'avocat général eu égard à la
personnalité troublée et fragile de
florence rey eu égard à son âge
également 19 ans au moment des faits
l'avocat général madame le chieur n'a
pas retenu la perpétuité mais trente ans
sans peine de sûreté ce qui permettrait
une liberté conditionnelle de florence
rey dans une douzaine d'années mais
attention ce ne sont que les récuse du
foé
les jurés de la cour d'assises de paris
up 2d ferait la plus ferme dans ses
réquisitions à dominique l'avocat
général a aussi très nettement dit que
florence rey était parfaitement
responsable du meurtre notamment du
meurtre du chauffeur taxi
oui on peut dire que l'accusation a mis
la barre haut de vol à main armée et
association de malfaiteurs cette
tentative de meurtre ce sont les blessés
de la place de la nation et du bois de
vincennes meurtre en qualité de co
auteur pour les trois policiers ceci
n'est presque pas contesté mais la
surprise de ce réquisitoire vous l'avez
dit c'est que pour l'accusation florence
rey a tué le chauffeur de taxi alors que
les experts en balistique ont soutenu
que les balles mortelles ont été tirés
par l'armp tenu par audry maupin alors
l'accusation se base sur des témoignages
contradictoires part d'un postulat
légèrement controversé à savoir que
durant la fusillade
audry maupin et florence rey se seraient
échangé des armes
l'avocat général reconnaît qu elle base
son accusation sur un flou balistique la
seule à ne pas avoir réagi à ces
réquisitions c'est florence répètes
baissé elle avait totalement disparu
dans son box
merci dominique à versailles les
magistrats de la cour d'appel en ont
fini ce soir de l'examen des faits
reprochés à jean marie le pen est commis
au mois de mai 97 aujourd'hui des images
tournées lors des incidents opposant les
militants du front national à ceux du
parti socialiste et à la candidate
futurs députés nouvelle va subir jase
ont été projetés une nouvelle fois la
décision de la cour d'appel sera mise en
délibéré après le réquisitoire qui doit
s'achever dans quelques minutes
monsieur le pen risque la confirmation
de son inéligibilité
reportage à versailles valérie ermite
guillaume fautrat
c'est le deuxième jour d'audience et ils
sont toujours là fidèle et patients les
militants du front national à tel point
que la femme de jean marie le pen
on est presque ému aux larmes
rovinescu à l'intérieur l'ambiance est
moins chaleureuse pour jean marie le pen
le fonctionnaire des renseignements
généraux qui selon lui aurait fait un
faux témoignage par pression de sa
hiérarchie
lors de la première audience est venu
redire que jean marie le pen s'était pas
arrêtée au niveau des
contre-manifestants nous et est
engouffré dans le groupe
la seule pression que j'ai subis dit le
policier c'est celle du front national
qui voulait que je dise que je n'avais
jamais vu ça il est également venu dire
que tout ce qu'il avait déclaré en
première instance
contrairement à ce que disait jean et le
pen s'était l'exacte vérité est que bien
évidemment ce jour là il y avait un
agresseur et agressé et que l'agressée
c'était bien évidemment mal apple va le
perdre et que l'agresseur s'était bien
évidemment que jean marie le but et je
ne m'attends pas à ce que les pollutions
de monsieur laurent soit favorable que
laurent est un commissaire des
renseignements généraux
c'est à dire à commissaire de la police
politique c'est dire qu'il n'est
absolument tort vous ne s'alliera le
complot politique et médiatico
judiciaire l'un des thèmes favoris de
jean marie le pen qui espère cette fois
une relaxe il sera fixé sur son sort le
17 novembre prochain à douai dans le
nord remise en liberté du soigneur belge
de l'équipe cycliste la française des
jeux monsieur jeff dont tu avais été mis
en examen le 18 septembre dernier pour
infraction à la loi anti dopage à la
suite de nouvelles agressions commis
cette fois ci à main armée contre des
agents de la sncf le trafic banlieue du
réseau sncf de paris-saint-lazare a été
paralysé la plus grande partie de cette
journée l'agression a été commise lundi
soir les syndicats mettent en cause
l'immobilisme des pouvoirs publics le
président de la sncf monsieur louis
gallois a reçu au ministère de
l'intérieur a demandé des renforts une
compagnie de crs supplémentaire a été
affecté au réseau ile-de-france toute
cette journée a été très difficile pour
celles et ceux qui utilisent les
transports en commun puisque la ligne c
du rer était affecté par une grève du
personnel réclamant des moyens
supplémentaires
reportage yann fronty et patrick voix
l'agression par arme à feu de deux
boutons
aucun train déraille désert depuis ce
matin le trafic banlieue sur le réseau
saint-lazare est totalement paralysée
sur le quai cet après midi une
quarantaine d'agents sncf active
ils sont là pour accueillir les quelques
usagers qui n'ont pas été prévenus à
temps des usagers qui ne cachent pas
leur colère
elle et ses deux enfants qui sont âgés
et lui par une vivons tous elle se
débrouillait ce matin débrouillez-vous
les enfants mais papa et maman doivent
aller au travail voilà et on est venus
en voiture
à l'origine de cette grève spontanée
l'agression hier soir de deux cheminots
dans la petite gare de saint nom la
bretèche victime d'une attaque à main
armée
ils ont dû remettre leur caisse leur
carte bancaire et leur argent avant
d'être ligoté aujourd'hui l'un des deux
agents a bien voulu témoigner très
violent on a l'habitude d'être bousculé
peut-être des agressions verbales mais
là ce sera bien le stade supérieur
bah c'est pas imaginer qu'on met un
revolver sur la tempe
voilà je fais plusieurs plusieurs fois
quand même on tire la sonnette d'alarmé
ou l'agent est tout seul dans une gare
vous me demandez herbe avec une petite
porte vitrée un verrou qu'un enfant
pourrait ouvrir et puis un jour ou
l'autre c'était vraiment tenté de dire
non c'est qu'il ya de l'argent dans
cette gare en plus et il était facile de
mettre une porte blindée de prendre des
mesures avant que le drame n'arrive
on est arrivés les mesures dont on voit
deux prises mais toujours trop tard côté
direction le problème de la sécurité du
personnel est pris très au sérieux
mais le président de la sncf l'a affirmé
ce matin face aux syndicats à saint
lazare il ne trouvera pas seul toutes
les solutions ça concerne la sncf
ça concerne le ministère l'intérieur ça
concerne le ministère de la justice pour
que nos agents et capacité à intervenir
dans des situations délictueuses
ça concerne les collectivités locales
louis gallois a reçu ce matin des
renforts du ministère de l'intérieur
80 crs supplémentaires ont d'ores et
déjà été mobilisés les grévistes quant à
eux de long d'une augmentation des
effectifs et discutent toujours ce soir
des suites à donner à ce mouvement
la ville de cognac et la ville de jarnac
était totalement bloquée en fin
d'après-midi des viticulteurs de
charente et de charente maritime se sont
servis de leurs tracteurs pour
manifester et appelé à l'aide le
gouvernement est en effet une crise de
surproduction du cognac
visite officielle à paris du président
du liberia charles taylor élu l'an
dernier monsieur taylor a surtout fait
parler de lui comme chef de guerre lors
d'un conflit qui a duré sept ans et
coûté la vie à deux cent mille personnes
il y a moins de deux semaines encore de
violents combats avaient lieu à monrovia
la capitale du liberia monsieur taylor a
rencontré monsieur jacques chirac il est
venu chercher des aides financières en
france sur la visite du président du
liberia mais aussi sur l'histoire
récente de ce pays
les commentaires de patrice van den les
habits neufs de charles taylor costume
sombre cravate avec son bâton torsadé de
chefs africains
c'est avec les honneurs que le président
du liberia est reçu par son homologue à
l'elysée à la france charles taylor est
venu parler de la stabilité retrouvée du
liberia un pays à reconstruire
que cherche un homme d'affaires il
cherche où il peut investir ou réaliser
des projets cherche un contexte
favorable le liberia toutes ses qualités
nous avons des ressources des diamants
de l'or du bois le libérien est presque
un point chez nous l'environnement est
favorable avec un président
démocratiquement élu il y a une forme de
stabilité c'est le moment d'investir et
je suis sûr que les hommes d'affaires
français l'ont contraint de zapper cette
bonne parole charles taylor la prêche
auprès de jacques chirac de quelques
ministres socialistes et de quelques
parlementaires
mais s'il parle si bien de l'avenir
c'est parce qu'il a un passé en 97 en
treillis que charles taylor s'exprimait
devant les caméras il était à l'époque
l'un des chefs de guerre du liberia en
proie à une guerre civile qui aura duré
sept ans entre pillages exécutions
sommaires l'opération se soldera par
deux cent mille morts et l'exode de plus
d'un million de civils
ses rivaux charles taylor les a éliminés
avant de se faire élire président l'an
dernier avec près de 80% des voix
alors bien sûr charles taylor n'est sans
doute pas le chef d'état dont rêve la
france mais cet homme là vaut mieux
qu'une guerre civile
voilà pourquoi charles taylor est si
bien reçu au pays des droits de l'homme
aux états unis à new york devant
l'assemblée des nations unies monsieur
yasser arafat a renoncé a déclaré qu'il
proclame devrait un état palestinien
mais 99 date prévue pour la conclusion
du processus de paix d'oslo monsieur
arafat privilégie donc encore la
négociation d'une rencontre avec
monsieur net annuel devrait avoir lieu
d'ici la fin août
depuis ce mardi en israël la police
étaient placées en état d' alerte pour
le yom kippour le grand pardon les
territoires palestiniens ont été
bouclées à ramallah un militant du hamas
a été tué dans l'explosion d'une voiture
en allemagne et après la démission du
premier ministre monsieur fatos nano
annoncé hier il sent que ce soit un
proche de monsieur nano monsieur panda
l'image co âgé de 34 ans qui deviendrait
chef du gouvernement l'ancien président
et chef de l'opposition monsieur berisha
estime que la voie est plus verte
al ahly solution politique de la crise a
créé donc le départ de monsieur nano
l'on voit qu'ici à lyon la panne
d'électricité survenue à l'hôpital
edouard herriot aurait provoqué la mort
de cinq personnes et non de 2
le parquet de lyon a décidé l'ouverture
d'une enquête pour recherche des causes
de la mort il s'agit de savoir s'il ya
un lien de cause à effet entre la panne
de courant et la mort de ses cinq
patients cet après-midi les médecins de
cet hôpital s'expliquer à lyon pour
france 2 benoît gadret et thierry
simonet
après avoir distillé l'information
compte gouttes pendant trois jours et
sous la pression des médias la direction
de l'hôpital a enfin accepté de jouer la
transparence
elle a donc confirmé que deux des 26
malades transférés vers d'autres
hôpitaux après la panne d'électricité
était décédé
ce sont deux hommes âgés d'une
soixantaine d'années c'était des
personnes qui avaient des infections
cancéreux tous les deux qui avait été
opéré à plusieurs reprises et qui était
vraiment dans un stade médical de
polypathologies qui allait aboutir case
inexorablement au décès dans les heures
qui ont suivi la panne trois autres
patients maintenu en service de
réanimation à edouard herriot sont
également décédés parmi eux une
centenaire elle était en cours
d'opération quand l'électricité a été
coupée
nous estimons les médecins vous vous le
dire que ces décès pour nous était
inéluctable
le parquet de lyon a ouvert cet après
midi une enquête pour recherche des
causes de la mort il a demandé qu'une
autopsie soit pratiquée sur les corps
des deux patients transférés par
ailleurs le syndicat force ouvrière de
l'hôpital met en cause le contrat passé
avec une société privée pour assurer la
maintenance du système électrique
il y a eu une personne alliés ellis qui
étaient envoyés effectivement un quart
d'heure après le début de la panne
et puis ensuite ça n'est qu'une heure un
quart après qu'il y a eu l'intervention
d'une équipe avec des électriciens la
pièce défectueuse à l'origine de la
panne est en cours d'expertisé
mais les techniciens ne comprennent
toujours pas les causes de sa
détérioration
à tel point que la perspective d'un
nouvel incident n'est pas d'exclu 25e
anniversaire d'activité pour
l'association française pour le
dépistage et la prévention des handicaps
de l'enfant en 25 ans 20 millions de
français ont bénéficié d'un dépistage à
la naissance de quatre maladies graves
traitable ce programme de dépistage
revient à 35 millions de francs par an
c'est-à-dire un coût bien inférieur à
celui des handicaps
reportage à l'hôpital de
saint-vincent-de-paul en compagnie d'un
petit garçon prénommé andrea avec jean
daniel flaysakier roger mathurin à 5
jours andrea est plutôt du genre berson
loulo dodo mais ce matin c'est une autre
histoire
programme une petite piqûre au talon
indolores ou presque et petites gouttes
de son que l'on prélève pour mettre sur
un buvard but de l'opération dépister
d'éventuelles anomalies responsable
d'arriération mentale comme la
phénylcétonurie ou l'hypothyroïdie grâce
aux progrès de la biologie on a très
vite la réponse et c'est très important
ces petites tâches move par exemple sont
des tests positifs si rien n'était fait
les enfants auraient de graves troubles
mais heureusement grâce à un traitement
précoce et un régime en en 25 ans éviter
bien des malheurs on a donc détecter
7000 enfants qui avaient besoin d'un
traitement dès les premières semaines de
la vie
ces enfants ont été pris en charge dans
les différentes régions françaises
et on peut dire aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
normaux katia était l'un de ses bébés à
risque pendant neuf ans elle a suivi un
régime un peu particulier ça fait 3 de
manger au canada qui était d'origine
animale pas de protéines animales non
pas de viande pas de lèvres pas deux ni
leurs dérivés donc en gros j'étais
autorisé à manger des fruits et légumes
avec un produit de substitution pour les
vitamines et les protéines
aujourd'hui tout va bien katia juste
repris son régime pendant qu'elle
attendait le p'tit loup une fois la
prise de sang fini andrea lui a retrouvé
le cycle infernal
lolo berceau dodo le salon de l'auto qui
s'appelle maintenant le mondial de
l'automobile ouvrira ses portes au
public jeudi prochain mais il ya des
privilégiés notamment les journalistes
pour découvrir les nouveautés de ce
salon 40 modèles exclusifs sur le
catalogue fêtait pour nous par luc
d'aziz 1 et daniele
un oeuf de couleur verte c'est l'esprit
monospace compact présenté par citroën
peut être pour expliquer des lignes
inattendu le constructeur lui a donné le
nom de picasso commercialisation prévue
fin 99 chez l'italien fiat ce même type
de concept est retenu pour ce véhicule
baptisé multiples à son originalité deux
rangées de trois sièges
la voiture d'aujourd'hui se veut avant
tout conviviale et spacieuse c'est
pourquoi opel sera son tour ce monospace
de taille moyenne
appelée zafira mais les constructeurs se
lancent aussi à l'assaut des voitures
dites écologiques voici la moins
gourmande du marché donc la moins
polluante
la lutte au de volkswagen ne consomme
que 3 litres aux 100 km en fait du
diesel en injection directe autre
terrain de bataille commerciale les
petites voitures la 206 peugeot a
l'ambition de remplacer la 205 vieille
de 15 ans
les déclinaisons de ce modèle se
multiplient comme cette 206 appelé wrc
une gti des temps modernes pour
affronter les rallyes ce cabriolet au
toit rigide escamotable et ce modèle
escapade une version loisirs et tout
chemin légèrement réhaussées pour
concurrencer la nouvelle peugeot ford
présente aussi une petite voiture la
focus
mais les grands modèles n'ont pas encore
dit leur dernier mot
maserati qui appartient maintenant au
groupe fiat se fait une peau neuve
ce coupé 3200 gt affiche son côté sport
et prestige mais il ne faudra pas qu'on
paie moins de 500 mille francs pour
l'obtenir
à partir de janvier prochain dans la
famille italienne la cousine alfa romeo
donne le jour à une grande routière la
166 de son côté l'américaine la chrysler
300 m vient chasser sur les terres du
haut de gamme européen
mais sur ce stand les vedettes ne sont
pas uniquement les voitures ce sont
aussi les hommes
ici le patron de chrysler est celui de
daimler nouvellement unis dans la même
société
ils se sont affichés pour la première
fois ensemble moi j'ai encore une autre
image de couple observez bien cette
image c'est le patron de peugeot à
droite et conçu folle sa compagne sur
lit de renault monsieur chouette there
mais ils seront tous les deux en direct
aux côtés de benoît duquesne demain dans
une page spéciale de cette édition
consacrée banque au salon de l'auto
les horaires de bien s'entendre ma
fédération française de cyclisme a
communiqué les noms des douze
présélectionnés pour les prochains
championnats du monde
discuter du 7 au 11 octobre aux pays bas
laurent jalabert fait partie de cette
présélection et puis chez les femmes il
faut noter qu'il y aura toujours jeannie
longo parmi les sélectionnés
football coupe de l'uefa ce soir y aura
monaco lot vienne bordeaux-lyon
blackburn et marseille olomouc pour
l'instant marseille mène 2 à 0
et puis metz rencontrer l'étoile rouge
de belgrade mais semaine de 1 mètre a
été battu 2 1 à l'aller
pour l'instant il ya donc prolongation
et peut-être tirs au but si on n'arrive
pas à se départager
un nouvel album de jane birkin c'est le
premier album écrit compose et sans
serge gainsbourg une manière de tout
recommencer avec un titre de poésie
c'est jane birkin à la légère
reportage au brier de l'air christophe
airaud jane birkin garde désert de fées
mutine et insaisissable en trente années
de carrière passée de ce côté de la
manche elle n'a cessé de se livrer en un
mélange irrésistible de pandore et de
gravité au petit lumière de quai d'orsay
sans juste allumé pour nous le panier
d'osier a disparu mais l'accent est
resté et si serge gainsbourg joue
désormais les fantômes se sont sous
chaux m6 solar ou zazie qui lui offre
aujourd'hui des versets vers chantés à
la légère
mélancolique mais sereine la jane qui
nous revient ressemblent encore à la
peur keane révélée aux français
c'était en 1969
petit
sage avait décidé de mieux utiliser je
crois vraiment comme comme savoie
féminin à lui deux de ses mélancolies de
ses doutes de de ce qui se passait pas
sa tête
vous vous rendez compte que vous parlez
presque plus de serge gainsbourg en ce
moment que de vous même
je ne sais pas pourquoi des gens sont
très liés quand on parle de ne passer
tout d'un coup il ya des cds personnages
de votre présent aussi parce qu'ils sont
des références constantes lui papa papa
lui
à manger cet album comment le
percevez-vous comme une renaissance
comme un défi comme une chance c'est
peut-être pas chance et si elles
marchent pas ou si les gens du mal à
concevoir et bien ou moins on aurait
tenté on a pas on n'a pas été prudents
ici tout est que font qu'on avait ce
qu'il faut pour être heureux je trouve
que j'ai eu une vie vraiment bien
vraiment bien heavy
avant la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle quelques unes des informations
nous avons développé l'avocat général a
réclamé la confirmation de la peine
concernant monsieur le pen donc une
peine d'inégibilité monsieur jean pierre
chevènement 10 l'intérieur est sorti de
la salle des soins intensifs
et puis monsieur lionel jospin a annoncé
à tour devant une journée parlementaire
notamment une réforme de dialyse est
nous avons parlé avec notre invité mais
anne catherine trautmann dur un débat en
décembre pour vous téléspectateurs il y
aura notamment moins de pub sur les
chaînes publiques puis à l'hôpital
edouard herriot
il y aurait eu cinq personnes décédées à
la suite de la panne d'électricité lundi
la météo dans quelques instants avec
nathalie rihouet l'épreuve soit pas
terrible à 20h50 un film la petite
arnaqueuse et puis à 22h50 je vous
recommande la vie à l'endroit le
magazine de mireille dumas a consacré à
l'association d'alpinistes christine
janin à chacun son everest fsi de jeanne
a conduit des enfants malades sur les
plus hauts sommets du monde à 0 heures
25 le journal récurrence duprat et puis
le cercle de philippe lefait consacré un
hammam jeanne moreau 7h50 demain
françoise laborde reçoit bertrand
collomb pdg de lafarge à 13h retrouverez
carole et rachid et à demain 20h bonsoir
merci
au tout